the things that faulkner pulls off it's
it's just
so like what
[Music]
until at last the president of the board
of supervisors crossed the square to the
bank and on to that back room where old
snopes sat with his feet propped on that
mantelpiece between foreclosures and i
would have liked to hear that the
outsider coming in and saying more or
less can't you for god's sake keep your
daughter at home or at least out on
out of the courthouse that's one
sentence
the audacity that's what we talk about
with faulkner isn't it
we we talk about the the [ __ ]
audacity of this
this guy i am here to let you know you
don't have to be scared
of all of the rambling sentences of all
of the stream of consciousness of all of
the
things just just roll with it i guess
that's what i say
like most people i was forced
to read william faulkner in high school
which
is a crime against high schoolers in
high school
we were given to read the short story a
rose for emily and
the novel as i lay dying here are the
problems i have with
this approach to faulkner he wrote such
a vast array
some of it is pretty accessible and some
of it is really
hard to get into i think a rose for
emily is perfectly fine
it's a good short story i think it's a
good way to get a taste you're kind of
getting a watered down
flavor a rose for emily really doesn't
display what is so magnificent
about this guy's writing on the other
hand you have as i lay dying which is
probably one of his best books
it's definitely one of the weirdest i
mean you have one
chapter in the book that is just that
famous sentence my mother is a fish
we can all relate as i lay dying is is
pretty complex even though it's short i
honestly feel like high schools pick it
because it's just short it's kind of
like a puzzle there's ton of povs
the povs shift rapidly there's
perspectives from
the children from horrible characters
from
a character who's going somewhat insane
and even from a dead person
it really benefits on repeat readings it
benefits from
close analysis which is is great in high
school but that's not how you
enjoy the reading and honestly some of
the writing in as i lay dying i think is
supposed to be
alienating it's supposed to make you
feel a little weird and creeped out to
me
why i always return to faulkner is
because of that
narrative voice that presence that he
has on the page
that just carries you into this poetic
almost like cinematic even when the
story to me
is weird bizarre i still get pulled in
other places i
wouldn't start are with absalom absalom
i know everyone says don't start with
absalom absalom some people say just
don't read it which is stupid
if you want to start there just do it
just read it you know it's a good book
it's readable it's not like you're gonna
die if you try to read it you just have
to be a little patient
another place to probably not start is
the sound and the fury i personally
prefer the faulkner style that is very
narrator driven that's the rhythm in the
sentences is just
no other writer can make a sentence like
that so these books like as i lay dying
and the sound and the fury and even
sanctuary a little bit there's this kind
of
alienating modernist feel to them even
though you could call his other
books modernist they don't really go as
far as these books in terms of
separating the the text from the author
i struggled with faulkner until finally
i picked up the book that would change
me
this book invited me in in a way that as
i lay dying hadn't
four words right in august three words
what a book
what a book it's a story about a few
people in the town of jefferson
which is a fictional town based on
oxford mississippi the place where
faulkner lived it contains some of his
most
memorable characters it's so hard to
even talk about the plot of some of
these books because it just seems like
books that are carried with through
sheer force of their their characters
issues of race there's issues of class
and gender
and what keeps me reading faulkner
always even when the story gets
dull or slow or takes some kind of weird
side road that i wasn't expecting or i
don't know what's going to happen
i always feel like i guess this is the
advantage of
writing really long sentences you just
want to get to the end of the freaking
thought
at to the end of the sentence you just
want to get to the end of the
point he'll start a paragraph or even a
whole chapter
saying something something this thing
but and then he'll talk about the butt
for pages and then he'll just go back to
what he was actually talking about
and it's like you just you get lost you
get you
get pulled into all these different
threads my biggest advice
for anyone who wants to read any
faulkner book
any of the books i think you should
start with the light in august but
you could start anywhere if you just
keep in mind to always
move forward if there's one theme in his
books
that i think carries through all of them
is this battle between
motion and stasis this battle between
change and trying to freeze reality you
aren't going to
absorb everything sometimes you're not
even going to remember how the sentence
even started
sometimes he'll start a scene without
describing anything
without just just describing the the
feelings of the characters their
motivations and then finally
at the end of the scene you realize you
know it clicks what it all meant
i think that everyone needs to give it a
shot the way he's able to get inside the
emotions
and let it all out in such a rest
unrestrained
audacious way it's so refreshing
when so much of what i read now
and so much of i think books being
published today
are very safe and restrained
another great place to start with
faulkner it is this trilogy right here
uh starts with the mansion starts with
the hamlet
ends with the mansion the town is the
middle section
the the hamlet is kind of just disarming
because
it kind of starts off very normal in a
sense
we learn about little area called
frenchman's bend
outside of the fictional jefferson the
whole trilogy is about this individual
named
flem snopes who in my mind is kind of
this
embodiment of capitalism i mean the
whole series
is about him yet he plays such he's
barely in it he barely has any lines
you're telling this
almost horror story about this
monstrous inhuman greedy soulless
person and it's all about the people who
orbit him it's all about
all of the peripheral characters the
kind of
sad tragic funny weird stuff
that happens over a period of like 50
years
the descriptions of characters in in the
hamlet and just in in all of fucker's
work
just so incredible now varner could see
his face a pair of eyes of a cold opaque
gray between shaggy greying irratible
brows and a short scrabble of iron gray
beard as tight and knotted as a sheep's
coat
where you been farming varner said west
he did not speak shortly he merely
pronounced the one word with a complete
inflectionless finality
as if he had closed a door behind
himself this stuff
the writing in the hamlet is so
wonderful but be warned if you're
starting with the hamlet it gets
really [ __ ] weird there the things
that faulkner pulls off
it's it's just so like what
there's a chapter in the hamlet that is
literally just about
a guy [ __ ] a cow
probably like 50 pages in this kind of
romantic
poetic language and i know that sounds
so
weird but in the context of the book
it's like
what what is happening and these kinds
of things where he'll he'll take these
narrative turns or do these things with
characters that's just like
this is horrible these characters are
disgusting
i need to know what happens to them
so some things i would be a little wary
of
okay a lot of things a lot of use of the
n-word
a lot of disturbing sequences
and scenes in some of his books light in
august has one of the most
disturbing deaths i've read
he writes he's gonna he writes about
things that gets to
weird areas of of life
the cow stuff in the hamlet is an
example
gavin stevens in the town and the
mansion
is problematic
i will leave it at that the way faulkner
writes
women very male gazy never really
gets into the mindset of women as he
does i think lena grove
in light in august is a is a great
example there's a lot to um
consider yeah so this is my little
collection
if any of you know a a great place to
start with faulkner or if you think that
there are other ways to
to go about reading his work just um
write something in the comments section
or just call me on my personal phone
number it's
5-2 i shouldn't i shouldn't give out my
phone number william faulkner
he's he's dead